if your cat's food currently looks like this
and you want it to look like this
then you should
start by trying to make it look like this.
and by that I mean
to focus on getting your cats on a moisture rich base
rather than adding a thousand things to their bowl.
because cats are obligate carnivores
their body is designed to get most of
their hydration needs through their food.
and because of this,
that makes most wet food diets a much better option
than even higher quality dry food diets.
you're going to achieve a much better outcome
and a healthier,
happier cat
by simply switching your base to a moisture rich diet
than you would with a high quality kibble
and adding a thousand things to it.
I know you guys see me add a bunch of toppers.
and it took me a really long time to get to this point.
not only are cats obligate carnivores,
they're imprint eaters.
so it can be incredibly difficult to swap over your cat
to a new type of food.
so it's not only important,
but it's probably a lot easier on you mentally
to focus on just getting their base switched over
than it is to focus on anything else.
you can always build on a good base,
but it's really hard to make up for a bad base.
dry food is essentially the opposite
of what a cat's body is designed to digest and process.
so it puts a tool in their digestive system,
their urinary system,
and their oral health overall.
I'm sure you've heard that the crunch in the kibble
is good for your pet's teeth,
but it's actually the opposite.
carbohydrates
and dry food actually contribute to plaque buildup.
and even if they were actually chewing their food,
it would kind of be like brushing your
teeth with a candy bar.
I understand how overwhelming this can be,
so focusing on your base is a really
great starting point.